اعتمد مجلس الامن الدولي قرارا يمدد العمل
باليه ادخال المساعدات الانسانيه عبر
الحدود الى سوريا لمده سته اشهر
وسوطت لصالح القرار الذي قدمته البرازيل
وسويسرا جميع الدول الاعضاء في المجلس
ويمددها القرار عمل الاليه حتى العاشر من
يونيو المقبل وبموجبه يتعين اصدار قرار
جديد لاي تمديد اخر ويصبح القرار بادخال
المساعدات الانسانيه عبر معبر باب الهواء
على الحدود مع تركيا دون اذن من النظام
السوري
انا اعداد المحتاجين الى مساعدات
الانسانيه في سوريا تجاوزت 15 مليون سنه
في رقم من هو الاعلى منذ عام 2011
وبحسب تقرير فريق المنظمه فان اكثر من 50%
من المحتاجين صنفوا على درجه شديده من
الاحتياج وكانت تقارير اماميه قد على 85%
من العائلات عاجزه عن تامين احتياجاتها
الاساسيه واكثر من 12 مليون نسبه يعانون
انعدام الامني الغذائيه